20h local de l'association Mieux Vivre
au valiibou à plaisir comme souvent des
résidents se réunissent une vingtaine
ils échange autour d'un café avant de
dresser un plan d'action pour le soir
monessieur Bonsoir Merci de votre
attenstion pour ce soir c'est c'est je
vous remercie quand même voilà on va
continuer
notre travail notre médiation vous savez
comme ce soir on n'est pas on n'est pas
l'état on n'est pas la police vous savez
ça on a aucun rlamation juridique on est
là des parents on est les grandspents
pour faire veiller sur notre quartier
vous savez le quartier est en train de
dégrader on a besoin de veiller sur
notre quartier nous les parents depuis
plusieurs mois avec des moyens du bord
il chassent les incivilités commises le
plus souvent par des squatterurs c'est
des jeunes de quartier comme mon fils
comme mes enfants c'est des jeunes on le
parle gentiment mais ils sont vraiment
ils écoutent ils disent bon il y a pas
de problème le but faut pas dégrader le
quartier parce que ça coûte trop trop
cher on est en crise en ce moment les
gens ils ont du mal à payer leur loyer
si vous le aajouz encore de de
dégradation à payer c'est un peu ce soir
là quelques jeunes avec eux autour de la
table et un message parfois encore
difficile à faire
passer nous on n pas d'activité il fait
froid d'IR on est obligé d'aller dans
les bâtiments et voilà nous après
l'école quand on sort de l'école nous on
fait quoi nous on fait nos devoirs après
on sort il y a quoi faire il y a rien on
va au stade c'est privé c'est par petit
groupe de 4 à si personnes que c'est
patrouilles évolue de himmeuble en
himmeuble quelques mètres à peine et
première Hal voilà on constate ce vitre
était pas cassé hier aujourd'hui il est
cassé vois et ça c'est mauvais ça fait
300 350 € ça ne coûte n les parents
l'inspection se poursuit dans l'immeuble
étage par étage pas de nouvelle
dégradation ce bâtiment attend d'être
rénové dans les prochains mois ces
patrouilles c'est aussi l'occasion de
rencontrer les jeunes un peu plus loin
un échange s'engage avec deux d'entre
eux l'action des locataires est salué
mais les mêmes revendications
ressurgissent pas de lieu pour se
rencontrer mais aussi pas d'emploi bien
sr bien sr c'est des je qui nous aussi
on est des citoyens comme tout le monde
on mange on vit on dort pareil
maintenant la seule différence c'est
l'emploi l'emploi et puis la vie sociale
où on vit exactement nous on n pas des
méchants on accueille tout le monde
22h30 fin de la ronde bilan de la soirée
quelques vitres cassées et quelques tags
un travail qui semble porter ses fruits
les dégradations seront signalées au
bailleur social mais ces patrouilleurs
tiennent à le préciser pas question de
se substituer aux forces de l'ordre pour
nous la police est très important il
faut qu'il vient au quartier parce qu'on
a besoin de la
police sécé c'est très important pour
not voilà voà prochaine étape obtenir le
statut de correspondant de nuit délivré
par les pouvoirs public ce serait une
reconnaissance mais aussi l'assurance
d'obtenir des moyens supplémentaires
préfecture et municipalité doivent se
prononcer ce système est déjà en place à
mon la
jolie